LP : Je pense que cela peut être très, très bientôt.
Nous avons parcouru bien plus de 150 000 kilomètres
de façon totalement automatisée.
Je suis très excité de sortir cela rapidement.
CR : Mais vous ne parlez pas uniquement de voitures automatisées.
Vous avez cette même idée pour les vélos.
LP : Chez Google, nous avons eu cette idée
de fournir des vélos gratuits à tout le monde,
et la plupart des voyages ont été géniaux.
Vous voyez des vélos aller partout,
et les vélos s'abîment.
Ils sont utilisés 24 heures sur 24.
CR : Mais vous voulez aussi les mettre au-dessus des rues.
LP : Je me suis dit : Comment est-ce que l'on pousse
les gens à plus utiliser des vélos ?
CR : Nous avons sûrement une vidéo.
LP : Oui, montrons la vidéo.
Je suis tellement excité à ce propos.
(Musique)
Voici comment on pourrait séparer
les vélos des voitures avec un coût minimal.
Enfin, cela paraît totalement fou,
mais je pensais à notre campus,
à travailler avec des gens plein d'entrain,
essayant d'augmenter l'utilisation de vélos,
et je me disais :
comment séparer les vélos des voitures
de façon rentable ?
J'ai recherché
et j'ai trouvé ceci.
On ne travaille pas vraiment dessus,
cette chose en particulier,
mais cela met en route votre imagination.
CR : Laissez-moi finir avec ceci.
Donnez-moi une idée de la philosophie dans votre propre esprit.
Vous avez cette idée de Google X.
Vous ne voulez pas juste
progresser un peu, de façon mesurable.
LP : Je pense
que beaucoup de choses dont nous avons parlé sont comme cela,
elles sont vraiment --
j'utilise presque le concept économique de l'additionalité,
qui signifie que vous faites quelque chose
qui ne se produirait pas si vous ne le faisiez pas.
Et je pense que plus vous faites ce genre de choses,
plus vous avez d'impact,
et il est question de faire des choses
que les gens pourraient croire ne pas être possibles.
Et j'ai été stupéfié,
plus je m'intéresse à la technologie,
plus je me rends compte que je ne sais pas,
et c'est à cause de l'horizon technologique,
la chose qui semble être la prochaine à faire,
plus vous en savez sur la technologie,
plus vous savez ce qui est possible.
Vous apprenez que les ballons sont possibles
parce qu'il existe un matériau qui va les faire fonctionner.
CR : Ce qui est également intéressant à votre propos, en ce qui me concerne,
c'est que, nous avons beaucoup de personnes
qui pensent au futur,
et elles vont et viennent et cherchent,
mais nous ne voyons jamais l'implémentation.
Je pense à quelqu'un que vous connaissez
et sur qui vous avez lu : Tesla.
Pour vous, quel est le principe de cela ?
LP : Je pense qu'inventer n'est pas suffisant.
Si vous inventez quelque chose,
Tesla a inventé l'énergie électrique que nous utilisons,
mais il a peiné à la transmettre aux gens.
Cela a dû être fait par d'autres.
Cela a pris beaucoup de temps.
Et je pense que si nous pouvons combiner les deux choses,
si on se concentre à la fois sur l'innovation et l'invention,
plus la capacité de vraiment -- une entreprise
qui peut vraiment commercialiser des choses
et les apporter aux gens
d'une façon positive pour le monde
et donner de l'espoir aux gens.
Je suis stupéfié par le projet Loon,
à quel point les gens étaient excités
parce que ça leur donnait de l'espoir
pour les deux tiers du monde
qui n'ont actuellement pas un bon accès à internet.
CR : Cela est une seconde chose à propos des entreprises.
Vous êtes l'une de ces personnes qui croient que
les entreprises sont des agents du changement
si elles sont bien dirigées.
LP : Oui, je suis très inquiet
que la plupart des gens pensent qu'en fait les entreprises sont le diable.
Elles reçoivent une mauvaise critique.
Et je pense que c'est en partie vrai.
Les entreprises font ce même processus d'incrémentation
qu'il y a 50 ans
ou qu'il y a 20 ans.
Ce n'est pas vraiment ce dont nous avons besoin.
Nous avons besoin, particulièrement dans la technologie,
nous avons besoin d'un changement révolutionnaire,
pas d'un changement progressif.
CR : Une fois, vous avez dit,
je pense que je l'ai bien compris,
que vous pourriez considérer,
plutôt que de donner votre argent,
si vous deviez le donner à une certaine cause,
simplement le donner à Elon Musk,
parce que vous aviez confiance
dans le fait qu'il changerait le futur,
et que, pour cette raison, vous --
LP : Oui, si vous voulez aller sur Mars,
il veut aller sur Mars,
pour sauvegarder l'humanité,
c'est un digne but, mais c'est une entreprise
et c'est philanthropique.
Je pense donc que nous tendons à faire des choses similaires.
Et je pense, vous demandiez, que nous avons beaucoup d'employés
chez Google qui sont devenus plutôt riches.
Les gens se font beaucoup d'argent dans la technologie.
Beaucoup de personnes dans la pièce sont plutôt riches.
Vous travaillez parce que vous voulez changer le monde.
Vous voulez le rendre meilleur.
Pourquoi la société pour laquelle vous travaillez
n'est-elle pas digne non seulement de votre temps
mais aussi de votre argent ?
Nous n'avons pas cette vision.
Ce n'est pas la façon dont nous pensons aux entreprises,
et je pense que c'est triste,
parce que les entreprises représentent le plus gros de nos efforts.
C'est là que la plupart des gens passent leur temps,
c'est où il y a beaucoup d'argent,
et j'aimerais que nous aidions
plus que ce que nous faisons actuellement.
CR : Avec beaucoup de monde, lorsque je finis une conversation
je pose cette question :
Quel état d'esprit,
quelle qualité d'esprit
vous a le mieux servi ?
Des gens comme Rupert Murdoch m'ont dit la curiosité,
et d'autre gens dans les médias m'ont dit cela.
Bill Gates et Warren Buffett ont dit la concentration.
Quelle qualité d'esprit,
alors que je quitte cet auditoire,
vous a permis de penser au futur
et en même temps
de changer le présent ?
LP : Je pense que la chose la plus importante est --
J'ai regardé beaucoup d'entreprises et les raisons
pour lesquelles je pensais qu'elles n'avaient pas réussi dans la durée.
Les entreprises faisaient du chiffre d'affaire plus rapidement.
Et j'ai dit : fondamentalement, qu'ont-elles fait de travers ?
Qu'est-ce que toutes ces entreprises ont mal fait ?
Et, généralement, c'est juste que le futur leur manquait.
Donc je pense,
j'essaye juste de me concentrer là-dessus et de dire :
que va vraiment être le futur
et comment est-ce qu'on le crée,
et comment est-ce qu'on amène nos organisations
à vraiment se concentrer là-dessus
et à avancer très vite ?
Et la réponse est la curiosité,
c'est rechercher les choses
auxquelles les gens n'ont peut-être pas pensé,
travailler sur des choses sur lesquelles personne d'autre ne travaille,
parce que c'est là que se trouve vraiment l'additionalité,
et avoir la volonté de faire cela,
de prendre ce risque.
Regardez Android.
Je me sentais coupable de travailler sur Android
au début.
C'était une petite start-up que nous avons achetée.
Ce n'était pas vraiment ce sur quoi nous travaillions.
Et je me sentais coupable de passer du temps là-dessus.
C'était stupide.
C'était le futur, n'est-ce pas ?
C'était une bonne chose sur laquelle travailler.
CR : C'est génial de vous voir ici.
C'est génial de vous entendre,
et c'est un plaisir d'être assis à cette table avec vous.
Merci, Larry.
LP : Merci.
(Applaudissements)